my name is Meagan Martin I am a
professional rock climber and today
we're gonna talk about transitioning
from the gym to the crag one of the main
reasons someone would want to transition
from climbing in the gym all the time to
climbing a crag is because it's really
just a whole experience versus just
getting your train on in the gym there's
a lot of great apps that climbers can
use to find the crags outside I use
these tools all the time if I don't know
exactly where I'm supposed to go looking
at mountain project on my phone I can
tell you exactly where to get there and
it's super easy you really want to pad
the area in a way to keep yourself as
safe as possible and sometimes there's
some trial and error you might fall and
take us down my bad fall and be like
okay clearly we need this place covered
a little bit more than this other part
right or maybe next time we need to
bring three more pads if you are
spotting you really need to be paying
attention to the climber the whole time
and help them feel safe I think starting
at pocket dawn
talked about what you guys need to focus
on before the climber starts climbing
and then while they're climbing
reassuring them with I got you I'm with
you those kind of words are definitely
helpful to the climber
it's really important to make sure you
bring enough fuel and water for your
entire day I always find it really easy
to just pack a handful of bars because
they're really high in nutrition and
they can give you enough energy for your
approach the climbing the hike out and
then you're set sometimes you have to
grab really sharp holes and you might
rip your skin you'll start to get used
to it and your skin will definitely get
tougher and you'll figure out ways on
how to keep it in its best shape
sometimes you're really high off the
ground and you feel pretty exposed so
you have to get adjusted to getting
through those uncomfortable situations
it's important to push yourself but it's
also important to know your limits so
that you don't find yourself in a
situation that you're not prepared for
if you remember proper safety and you
can prepare yourself mentally and
physically you'll set yourself up for a
successful day at any crag
you
[Music]